he got that fish yet hmm they're both oh
yeah ya did happy ending not exactly the
old man met his greatest adversary just
when you thought that part of his life
is over why didn't he just let the fish
go all man's got to be the old man
fissures gotta be the fish gotta be who
you are in this world right no matter
what nope I bet you got the personal
dollies at your old job did you guilty
as charged you do a refund for me when
you're done open the register all right
now move give me that ring it was simple
well he's okay Jenny what's your knowing
about it is about a guy who's a knight
in shining armor except he lives in the
world we're nice don't exist unless i
right
I think you can be anything you want to
be change your world I promise I would
never go back to being that person so
when somebody does something unspeakable
there's no you hardly know you do
something about cuz you can I mean about
a girl 16 seconds
that
19 seconds
he didn't take out five Kemp's you took
out the East Coast hub of the Russian
mafia a man with his skill I want to
know who he really is he won't stop
until he kills you and anyone you care
about suppose all the weight of a
toddler
enough cuz I can keep going brick by
brick body by body what do you see when
you look at me what do you see when you
look at me it's too late the start Oh
finga think I know